u.s president joe biden began his first
state of the union address by strongly
denouncing the russian president and his
invasion of ukraine
russia's vladimir putin sought to shake
the very foundations of the free world
thinking he could make it bend
to his menacing ways
but he badly miscalculated and now the
u.s will make putin pay
biden has directed the department of
justice to assemble a task force
targeting the crimes of russian
oligarchs and that we will join our
allies in closing off american airspace
to all russian flights further isolating
russia
[Applause]
a majority of americans do not believe
the u.s should play a major role in
working with allies to support ukraine
but biden argued if not confronted
russian aggression would spread
throughout our history
we've learned this lesson when dictators
do not pay a price for their aggression
they cause more chaos
they keep moving
and the cost the threats to the america
and america to the world
keeps rising given the focus on the
ukrainian crisis in biden's speech in
the audience was the ukrainian
ambassador to the u.s aksana markharova
a guest of the first lady dr jill biden
the russian invasion has increased
already record high energy prices and
inflation in the u.s and is threatening
biden's promised economic recovery one
way to fight inflation is to drive down
wages and make americans poor
i think i have a better idea to fight
inflation
lower your costs not your wages
[Applause]
but republicans in their response argued
biden has sent the country back to the
early 1980s
when runaway inflation was hammering
families a violent crime wave was
crashing our cities and the soviet army
was trying to redraw the world map
on wednesday president biden travels to
the u.s state of wisconsin to sell his
domestic agenda but foreign policy
challenges in ukraine are almost certain
to overshadow that effort
kimberly hellcat al jazeera capitol hill